if Jesus is teaching that he's the son
of God and not in the sense that he's
just some simple servant like the others
but he's the son of God the beloved Son
of God who is the a can he be teaching
this these things and be a
Muslim
[Music]
yes
God Central would you like to prove that
Jesus was a
Muslim uh well here's the thing when
you're I've been like listening to the
combo I had the shower my bad I would
have came up earlier I was at work but
um what when you're saying Pro Jesus was
a Muslim historically right that's
limiting it to one one
Avenue of just history right
so I could show you in the Quran where
Jesus is called a Muslim but you
wouldn't accept that right right it's
just a claim right so the word Muslim is
a verb right okay so it entails action
right now what is that action prayer
charity etc etc I mean we could see
throughout the New Testament Jesus doing
those things so by
default by definition he would you could
call him a
Muslim but if you're saying but if
you're go ahead yeah so so just to be
clear a Muslim is an action it's a verb
it's something you do charity prayer and
stuff does it matter who you're praying
to of course it does okay so if Jesus
was praying to someone that is not the
Islamic God or you know not that concept
of God then he couldn't be a Muslim
right sure but if you okay so can we
agree that Aramaic was Jesus's primary
language how do you know that I mean if
we're going by history that's what
history says and where do we get that
history
from historians
where do they get it from uh I don't
know like yeah you
do no I I truly don't I mean going so so
they they they get it from the New
Testament uh there's it's be it's it's
because of the New Testament that places
Jesus in first century Palestine that
they conclude that his colloquial
language was Aramaic
sure I have no issue with that so you
agree that his primary language was
Aramaic
as long as we're sticking to the
historical evidence yes which is in the
New Testament yeah I agree cool then
when Jesus
uh when Jesus would have ever used the
word God he would have been using the
word Allah because the Aramaic word for
God is
Allah that's not the Aramaic word
however that's not a big deal to me
because God just means or you're just
saying Allah means god
right
elaborate you're just saying that the
word Allah just simply means
god the god of the god of Abraham Isaac
Jacob okay so Allah is specifically the
god of Abraham Isaac and Jacob and so
you're saying that Allah that we find in
the Quran is the same God of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob that Jesus preached and
believed in and prayed to right yes I
believe there's a Biblical verse in
there as well that I
could so what was Jesus then when he
would pray to let's let's say that he's
praying to Allah let's say this name
let's use this if he's praying to Allah
what did he call
Allah Allah prayers no oh you're talking
about
father oh beautiful I got you so the
Jews calling god father is just a Jewish
idiom for like I'll give you an example
uh in the New Testament Jesus says let
me pull up the verse so I don't misquote
it
uh one second you talking about John
10 uh John
17 uh okay John 17 six I have revealed
you to Those whom you gave me out to the
world they were yours you gave them to
me and they have obeyed your
word but there's a there's another verse
where it says I reveal like
the uh KJV or if you want to go with
the like other translations it says I
have revealed your name to the people
you gave me from the world which are the
disciples right the belie so Jesus
taught his belie his disciples the name
of God yeah and and in verse one who is
he speaking
to uh I don't know
I just put my phone down if you want to
read it in verse in verse one he called
he says father glorify your son that
your son may glorify you okay so are you
saying that the name of God is Father no
the name of God is Yahweh but who he is
is the fathers that's what Jesus is
saying and that he's his father okay
question is that is that consistent with
Islam that Jesus is the son of Allah no
but again the the the word father is a
Jewish idiom because if you look at the
Old
Testament I believe there's a verse in
there that says I could be wrong that
says that the name of God Is So holy the
Jews didn't want to speak it I mean
historically speaking Yeah I mean even
today if you look at like Jewish
websites when they spell the word god
they cut like the they put a dash
through this uh through the G they spell
G Dash D it's it sounds like you're
fixated on the name of God rather than
who Jesus identifies God to be sure like
so that the this is two different things
that we're talking about so Jesus
identifies God as his father I got
you so is that can can you be a Muslim
and identify Allah as your father even
idiomatically not today
no so then Jesus wouldn't have been a
Muslim then
right uh
he would have at the time yes he would
have been so you're saying that once
upon a time Allah was a father of Jesus
not in the sense that you're saying
again this goes back to in in any sense
I'm asking in any sense is Allah father
to Jesus in any sense
no very good so that means that if Jesus
is saying that Allah is his father in
any sense then he's not a Muslim right
okay but again the word father is just a
Jewish idiom because they didn't know
the name of God whether it's an idiom or
whether it's literal whether whatever no
sense idiomatically figuratively
literally is Jesus the son of Allah no
okay so then that means if Jesus is
Calling Allah his father and saying that
he's the son of Allah even Ed
idiomatically he's not a Muslim
right not really I mean are you saying
not really are you wait what I don't
agree with you okay so I'm just using
what you're saying you agree with me
that in no sense idiomatically
figuratively literally whatever no sense
is Jesus the son of Allah yeah so for
okay so for example so if if Jesus let
me just finish this yeah so that's
that's that's premise one in no way
shape or form no sense idiomatically
whatever is Jesus the son of Allah two
premise two
Jesus identifies himself as the son of
Allah in some sense therefore Jesus
can't be a Muslim gotcha so if you go to
acts 3:13 it says the god of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob the god of our fathers
has glorified his servant Jesus very
good
okay wait can can you keep reading to 15
sure let me get back up one second
uh 13 okay the god of Abraham Isaac and
Jacob the god of our fathers has
glorified his servant Jesus who you
handed over to be unived and you
disowned him before Pilate though he had
decided to let him go you disowned the
holy and righteous one and asked that a
uh I don't want to say that word I don't
want to give you in be released to you
you un alived the author of life but God
raised him from the dead we are with
Witnesses they unive they un alived the
author of life sure who's the author of
Life Central according to that ver would
be
Jesus and according to a Muslim the
author of life is Allah right sure so
this is the the this is Peter saying
that Jesus is God who gave his life Up
In the Flesh and raised and the father
raised up this is Peter attributing an
attribute of God to Jesus
yeah which would be Sherk or
blasphemy on the
cross so this is a so now let's let's
let's hold on let me it's just me and
Central so with this verse we see that
Peter attributes Jesus to being God even
though he's distinct from the father and
who the father raised up who Jesus is in
his being the author of life was able to
lay his life down and take it back up
again that's that's that's tough now now
I I I assume you were focusing on the
part where he calls him God's servant
right uh the god of Abraham Isaac Jacob
yeah yeah okay so and you do you believe
that Jesus like when he says he's the
son of God that it's equivalent to him
being the servant of God uh okay so the
Son of God many people were called sons
of God this is the this is like the
Jewish belief at the time they beli they
were the sons and daughters of God
so then that would mean again that then
they're not worshiping Allah then
because Allah has no sons in any
sense no not true again this is just a
Jewish idiot they didn't believe they
were literal Sons and Daughters of God
very good so okay I'm I'm ask you this
again
Central idiomatically is Allah does
Allah have children
idiomatically
no okay so if Allah does not have
children
idiomatically when the Jews are
referring to God as their father
idiomatically they're not talking about
Allah they're not Muslims sure okay so
when they say they're a Son of God
they're basically saying that they're a
servant of God it's not literal or like
very good so so are you say so let me
let me ask you this again when Jesus
refers to himself as God's son are you
saying that he is uh when he calls
himself God God's son that he's
equivalent to being God's servant like
those are just two words that could just
be swapped out of place yeah I could say
that sure okay so go to Mark chapter 12
Muslims love this chapter you
know I'm going to show you that Jesus
makes a distinction between himself and
the servants okay after this can I ask
you a question of course cool Mark 12
Mark 12 we're going to start at verse
one bro if I if I cough I'm sorry I got
my uh airpods in and I'm like away from
my device so if you're speaking and I
cough over you I apologize I'm sick it's
okay everybody pray for Central that the
Holy Spirit heals him that Jesus touches
him and covers him yeah amen hey you
you're in the right place
Central dude God L bro
in the right place Mark what okay let's
go Mark 12 we starting in verse one yep
okay says Jesus then began to speak to
them in Parables a man planted a
Vineyard he put a wall around it dug a
pit for the wine press and built a
watchtower then he rented
the then he rented the
vineyard uh to some farmers and moved to
another place at Harvest Time he sent
the servant to the tenants to collect
from them some of the fruit of the
vineyard but they see pay attention Okay
pay attention so the vineyard owner is
sending servants to these tenants right
yeah all right keep going so what are
they do to the servants but they seized
him beat him and sent him away
empty-handed then he sent another
servant to them they struck this man on
the head and treated him shamefully he
still he sent still another and that one
they un alive he sent many others some
of them they beat others were un alive
all right pause there so in this Parable
we're plugging in characters who are the
servants in this Parable uh the servants
would be the prophets I think is it or
exactly yeah yeah the prophet yep
absolutely and the vineyard owner would
be God right yeah got all right so God
is sending his servants and obviously
the tenants are Israel he's sending his
servants the prophets to Israel over and
over and over again they keep abusing
them killing them and y y y right yeah
all right very good so those are the
servants now verse six watch what he
watch who he sends okay he had one left
to send a stun whom he loved he sent him
last of all saying they will respect my
son pause here okay
so distinct from the servants he sends
his son who he loves
MH you see so do you see the distinction
there that there's there's a distinction
there's a a level up from the servants
and the sun yeah sure yeah God logic
look I'm not arguing against that the
Bible
uh I'm not arguing against the fact that
Bible teaches that Jesus is the son of
God or any of that I'm not
so okay so so good then so but let's so
I'm I'm just showing you that when Jesus
calls himself or identifies himself as
the Son of God that it's not in no no
you know regular sense like oh he's just
talking about his his servants now and
yes he is the servant of God but not
just that not merely the servant he is
his son his beloved
Son I think you could have just quoted
John
3:16 I could have but I but I wanted to
show you where specifically cuz since
you brought up like the the the term
servant I wanted to show you where Jesus
himself makes a distinction between him
being the Son of God and the Servants of
God the
prophets I'm going to show you I want to
just show you that
so with that being out the way if Jesus
is teaching that he's the son of God and
not of the sense that he's just some
simple servant like the others but he's
the son of God the beloved Son of God
who is the a can he be teaching this
these things and be a
Muslim
yes so so it's perfectly Islamic that
Jesus is the son of Allah who is the
heir of Allah who owns everything Allah
owns okay again it's just a Jewish idiom
we're going to keep going in
circles I know if you're saying it's a
Jewish idiom I'm asking is it perfectly
Islamic does it line up with Islam with
Muslim teaching that Jesus is the son of
Allah who is distinct from the servants
the prophets and who owns everything
that Allah owns is the heir of
everything that Allah possesses is that
Islamic islamically speaking no but then
we would have to go into like
preservation of taxt the Divinity of
Christ we would get into that you know
argument we don't have to go there you
want to know
why because you used this as your
criteria you use this as the Historical
Method of deciding or going back to see
what Jesus taught and believed
okay you you was okay with going here so
that's why can we at least say this that
according to the New Testament Jesus was
not a
Muslim uh according to the teachings of
the New
Testament I could agree to that sure
thank you so this is why this is
important because earlier we both agreed
that the New Testament is where we
historically get the information Jesus
so
historically since the New Testament is
the historical evidence that we have of
Jesus's life and what he taught and
believed we see that historically Jesus
was not a
Muslim say say that
again that because the New Testament is
where we get the historical information
of Jesus what he believed what he taught
how he lived where he lived things of
this
nature then we can conclude since the
New Testament the historical information
that we get on Jesus teaches that he's
not a Muslim then the historical Jesus
was not a
Muslim but that's presupposing that the
New Testament is
a is a
authentic uh reference to to history
like I'm sorry you did that earlier
that's why I asked you earlier did I do
that by acknowledging that the
historians get their information
historically about Jesus and you was
fine with that no I got I mean I don't
have no problem saying that sure okay so
then you that's when you that's you
acknowledging that the New Testament is
the is historically reliable about the
life of Jesus God okay so when the Quran
says that Jesus healed the blind that's
historically correct do you acknowledge
that the Quran is not historically uh
reliable the the Quran is getting
information come on bro that is that is
historical that's a historical fact that
Jesus healed the blind you see but you
see like the you see the double standard
like I I grant one thing I tell you sure
you know according to historians you
know if they derive their information
from the Bible the New Testament they
say Jesus spoke
Aramaic you say you then then you say
okay Central you're Grant you know
you're basically saying the New
Testament is reliable source for all
history but then I ask you the same
thing about the Quran and you're saying
it's just you know it's not the same
thing no well well no no what I'm saying
is is that when the Quran makes a a true
statement about the historical Jesus
that he healed the blind that is
substantiated based off of the
historical evidence we have of Jesus in
the New Testament that he healed the
blind so the Quran is right there but
it's not the source of the historical
information we have on Jesus it's
getting it from the new
Testament okay so you're saying that the
New Testament is
the okay so you're saying the Quran
copies the old uh the New Testament no
what I'm saying is is that the
information that it gets right about
Jesus historically is not rooted in the
Quran itself it's rooted in the New
Testament okay but where did the Quran
get it
from the Christians but you would have
to prove that
though well according to Muhammad he had
waraka who used to teach him and write
the the gospel in Arabic for him yeah
sure but waraka died within uh 3 years
after the first revelation that's that's
not too long so so according to that
that the time wara was a huge influence
on on muhamed's life taught him a lot he
was even he was very distraught when he
died sure uh so he had a teacher who was
a Christan but if you want I can tell
you when the verses of about about Jesus
healing the blind and all that were
revealed they were they were revealed
after Waka
B that that would make sense because
since that's after waraka would have
taught him that Jesus healed the Blind
and did these Miracles what bro how can
he teach him how can he teach him
something when the man is dead so if he
teaches him something dies and then
years later it comes out that Muhammad
is saying things about Jesus that
doesn't throw out the fact that once
upon a time wara taught him that before
he died but you do realize the man was a
literate right like he could who was the
prophet Muhammad okay so what how does
that stop him from hearing and learning
things because there's 77,000 words in
the Quran
and there a lot of it is similar to the
to the uh Old Testament and the New
Testament you would have to say that
this man remembered 77,000 words and
then just you know put them into a book
or you know claim to have recited them
well well no he just uh remembered
stories and remembered things I don't I
don't see how that's a problem he didn't
remember the whole Quran all the time
there was a lot of points where he
forgot portions of the Quran so but you
hold one second you would also okay so
would you agree that there was
Christians living at the time of the
Prophet uh when he received
Revelation one second
bro
my bad okay so you you would agree that
there was Christians that were living uh
during the time that the prophet uh
received
Revelation yes okay cool so when the
prophet for example when he says that
Jesus was a servant of Allah that he you
know created you know birds from clay a
bird from clay and breathed life into it
by the per of Allah he healed the leper
etc etc you don't think the Christians
would have called him out and said hey
you're copying our text is there any
evidence for any anybody doing that
because you have well yeah yes yes the
people in the it's in the Quran where
they literally accuses him of repeating
Parables that he has already heard or
that someone has taught to him and he's
just repeating it this is all over the
Quran where these these These are the
accusations of some of the people he's
reciting this stuff to yeah I'm talking
about historically because you have John
of
Damascus uh who lived at the time of the
prophet he despised the man but he never
once claimed that the prophet
plagiarized from the
Bible I I don't know too much about all
of that my my point is that that proves
nothing if we find information in the
Quran where we have evidence of him
being around Christians having a
Christian teacher who he was close to
who used to teach him all the all types
of things
uh listened to Jews who used to recite
the Torah in Arab in Arabic um and all
we see is just a little Islamic Twist on
it we see where these stories come from
these Gnostic Gospels and things of this
nature we see where this influence comes
from right that's that's the point we we
know when we're talking about what
Muhammad is is is uh saying about Jesus
he's not it's not he's getting it from
other people or stuff that he's made
made up himself
Now where's the evidence for
this uh for for example the story that
you mentioned right of him creating a
bird from clay that's in one of the
infancy gospels of Thomas I believe yeah
but the infancy Gospel of Thomas says
that there was many
birds doesn't matter so if you have
where this if you have where this story
is that pops up in a Gnostic Gospel
centuries before Muhammad and then you
see him plug that story Into the Quran
just with a little edit
we know where that came from so if I
show you John 1 plagiarized from Hindu
scripture would you say that it's uh
plagiarism well that's not dude number
one that's not even in the H scripture
number two you're missing the point the
point is is that the Quran makes claims
about Jesus whether they're historically
accurate or not is what we're is what
we're
discussing okay which we which we see
when it comes to Jesus being a Muslim as
we concluded is not historically
accurate okay we could agree to disagree
no no worries can I ask my question you
you you agree with me I agreed to
according to the New Testament
sure so then there will be no way to
prove that Jesus was a Muslim then right
without the New Testament for Muslims I
mean the Quran is is our proof we don't
like we don't need anything outside out
yeah but but we believe that the Quan is
the verbatim word of God right
so God says I'm sorry go ahead so you so
you would agree then that you're that
you do have a claim as a Muslim just not
the proof historically you have a claim
though sure just like the New Testament
claims Jesus was crucified but it can't
be proved it's all hear but that's a
conversation for another
day okay what's your question
okay
so you have
Jesus the Father the Holy Spirit
right you agree are you asking me or are
you like setting this up no no I'm yeah
yeah I'm saying you have the Father the
Son and the
Holy okay go on go on I'm listening
actually let me rephrase you have God
logic Central dawa and who else is on
the
panel uh Sil right how many Natures is
there between the three of
us three we have three different
Natures no we have we each have our own
nature so although we're all human we
are three different human beings so
three Natures
here bro
what are we are do are you and me the
same being or are we two different
beings we're not the same being but we
share the nature of Being Human Beings
no so so okay so in a sense you have
where there's one nature here like under
the umbrella of
human um but we are three different
humans so there are three difference of
us right there's three different beings
of humans right but we're we share the
the nature of Being Human
Being uh sure by name yes what do you
mean by name I mean there's one human
nature like you you when you say that
you and I share the nature of human
being all you're saying is that we both
are humans that's what you're saying
even though there's two human beings
there's two of us yeah okay yeah
so it's not it's not the same with the
Trinity with the with the Trinity
there's only one Divine being one nature
with humans there's multiple human
beings right no no no okay with human
beings there's one nature but multiple
human beings
uh there's one human there's one human
uh human nature but if there's multiple
humans there's multiple you know what
I'm saying multiple it's only human one
human nature by like under the umbrella
of human is basically what it is bro
what that's not what that's not that's
not the Trinity where the Trinity
there's only one Divine Essence there's
only one God essence or God being one
Divine being sure I'm not arguing that
you have three separate uh natur within
the Trinity that's not my argument no we
don't no we don't right we don't Okay
cool
so you me still one nature three human
beings
correct sure we could say that cool now
if you look at the the
Trinity you have the Father the Son and
the Holy
Spirit would you agree that the property
of
being the Creator is a property that
belongs solely to
God sure okay cool is God the Father a
Creator he is the creator okay is God
the son the
Creator correct is God the Holy Spirit
the Creator correct okay so if you're
counting by the same way that we just
counted when it came to you me and Sil
how many creators do you
have it depends on in what sense you're
asking if you're asking how many uh
persons is the creator you have three
persons who are the Creator if you're
talking in being there's only one Divine
creator that exist as three persons okay
so so you're saying there's three beings
that can
create the no do you see how you just
strawman what I said no I'm asking you
to simplify did I so I I said I said
right in the beginning there's only one
being right and I think I literally just
said this just now when it came to the
one creator
if you're talking in being so the
property of of Creator is basically
being predicated to the
persons okay so when you're saying
there's only one Creator who is that
Creator that's God that's Yahweh who
consists of three distinct
persons okay so which which person out
of the Trinity would be the Creator the
the one Creator again the Creator
consists of three distinct persons so
but they all property of being the
Creator yeah that's that's predicated to
each person so the Creator is the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit the one
being okay but there's three creators
just like in the human just like when we
use the analogy there's three there
there's three persons who are the
Creator okay so would you say there's
three persons who have the property of
being the
Creator uh that's that's yes that's
predicated to three persons okay cool
that was that's it
that's that was it that's my question
that's all yeah oh my God
[Music]
logic